you
know
what if I told you there is actually two
ways that you can use iMessage on an
Android phone so the first version
actually does require you to have a Mac
as well so you might have heard
something called error message so you're
still signed into an Apple ID on that
Mac and then your Mac basically is used
as a server to forward the messages to
your Android phone so this works as long
as the Mac is always connected to the
internet at all times but then there's a
second method so there's an app that's
called beeper this one is invite only
right now but it's hopefully opening up
soon this app is literally made to
integrate all of your messages in one
place your texts your WhatsApp messages
and that includes iMessage by having you
log into an Apple ID which is pretty
cool but it also makes me slightly
suspicious that what's really happening
is you're logging into your Apple ID on
someone else's Mac in some server Farm
somewhere so as long as you're
comfortable with that then this is a
pretty cool solution that works but hey
if you really want the blue bubbles with
an Android phone technically you can
have it